bishop f4 is on the right track but it's
unnecessary the move is castles
you do nothing that's the answer
you're like what
what about knight takes e5 well this
loses the queen
you know the drill bishop takes f7 and
queen takes the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we actually gain a very important
positional trump card
which is then used essentially to win
the game
yeah the d6 square is incredibly weak he
says big fan by the way thank you
okay
what should we do now
how should we proceed
e5 is attacked
yeah opposite knight f3
knight f3
develop and defend
no shenanigans with queen h5 or queen f
it's too early for that
queen h5 g6 there's nothing
there for the taking we need to develop
first
notice how hard the spawn is making it
for black to do anything
yeah f4 is too weakening
it's not that f4 has an issue it's just
that it doesn't develop a piece it
blocks the bishop it weakens the king
it does all these small bad things and
we need to focus on our development
instead
g6
okay what now
we are tempi ahead yeah we're three four
tempe ahead now we don't change our
behavior because of that
i know a lot of you are attempted by
knight g5
but knight g5 fails for multiple reasons
one of them is knight takes e5 have you
forgotten about the pawn on e5
okay so
this is really interesting right because
we can play bishop g5 but the way that i
think about it i'm not sure exactly
where this bishop needs to go yet
i'm not even sure we need to develop the
bishop anytime soon
and this is a hard concept for me to
explain
but i think we should start by castling
because that is a move we know we want
to make right we know that we're not
going to regret castling but we might
regret putting the bishop on f4
because maybe black will play e6 and
then we'll want to go bishop g5 or
conversely maybe black will go d6 and
we'll want to play bishop f4 make the
like
moves that you know you have to make
first okay
so
now there's a little more clarity in the
situation
our pawn on e5 is attacked how should we
defend it we can defend it in a couple
of ways rookie one is a great move
but if you guys insist on developing the
bishop we'll do it bishop f4 if you guys
feel a little bit like the bishop is
being left
alone at home while the other pieces are
parting okay
we're also preventing d6 because then we
take knight h6 good stuff by our
opponent he's trying to develop
fortunately black is so cramped
that we can basically win a piece here
very good queen d2
but do you see the follow-up after
knight f5 i gave you a pass
but what's the follow-up after knight f5
g4 very good g4 traps tonight that's it
knight if knight goes back to g8 then
it's really over
knight f5 and
boom
there is the extra piece ladies and
gentlemen
now perhaps some of you are thinking
well
how do you know that i can weaken my
king like this
well first of all a piece is a pretty
big damn deal right
winning a piece is usually worth
slightly weakening your king for
um but the other thing is just that
black is so passive and so cramped that
how can he even possibly hope to exploit
this slight weakening of our king yeah
knight d4 takes
okay black should have taken on e5 here
by the way that would have been the
lesser evil
now it's just a full
full piece
and we preserve all of the
[Music]
trumps of our position
and all the bidens um
okay
what should we do
well
again we have to prioritize we have two
priorities as i see it our first is that
there's this little x-ray going on it's
it's pissing me off it's annoying me
and because we're up a piece i can do
whatever the heck i want so a move like
queen e3 comes to mind the other thing
we haven't done is we haven't activated
our rooks
okay we can do anything in any order the
other last thing i'll say is the g4 pawn
is undefended
the g4 pawn is undefended so ideally i
would like to play h3 at some point now
you can't do any everything at once so i
vote we start by moving the queen off
and unpinning it
that just seems to be the safest way to
continue and then we'll we'll see
makes sense we're also potentially
aiming for bishop h6 which would trade
black's only piece that's not on an
initial square
or on the eighth rank rather
i don't like h4 no no no no we don't
need to we don't need this
we don't need a pawn attack we are we've
done the job with our pieces
i'll explain why afterward
okay rook 81 is a great move here i
think
yeah we could have played bishop h6 it
doesn't matter we're so winning here
anything wins
but let's just be methodical
yeah bishop h6 whatever you want to do
here knight okay queen a5
all right now not bishop h6 because it
blunders e5
okay proposal we centralize our knight
in preparation for bishop h6
how do we do that
yeah we can play rook d5 too but i like
i like uh
knight t5 let's go
center pieces in the center
also intercepting the queen
the queen's contact with e5 so bishop h6
is once again possible and likely
and then we go for mate
yeah so here we can fork we can fork the
rooks with knight c7
but it's not even necessary i think
black is going to resign
yeah i mean he resigns there's there's
not nothing to play for at this point
we can go here we can go b4 and
basically trap the queen
doesn't quite trap the queen but it
comes very close
smith more ladies and gentlemen
smith more ladies and gentlemen
knight f6 is bad now a couple of words
to the wise about the smith moore there
is no refutation
my recommendation if you're a sicilian
player is actually to decline it and go
knight f6
it's not in my interest to say that
because we're playing with white but i
think the safest and the most reputable
is to decline to go knight f6 if you're
accepting it you can get logos are's uh
course on chessable he's got a very good
good repertoire that suggests accepting
it i think he he gives like knight c6 e6
and a6 there's a couple of systems that
give like a good position it's not
refuted logos are claims that black is
slightly better if he plays accurately
that's possible
but it's complicated
just like the king's gambit is not
refuted
right refuted the latvian gambit is
refuted refuted to me means like plus
two or more slight edge doesn't mean
refuted
logan's our lines are very complicated
that is true
which is precisely why i propose for the
uh time
constrained club player knight f6 d3 is
bad don't go d3
this this this line is bad because white
goes c4 and creates the bind
benoni's also not refuted no
okay so knight takes e3 if you really
want to know ask mark tune into his
stream he streams like these hours the
d-gen hours
and uh you could ask him what he what he
recommends you can say i sent i sent you
uh it's why so serious with seven wise
knight f6 is a mistake very common one
forgetting about e5
back to g8
to tempe this is already essentially
losing for black for all intents and
purposes
we're all intentional e5 is bad
e5 is a common move among club players
but it's really really bad who can
explain to me why i assume you mean
black playing e5
f7 weakness yeah but it's already weak
bishop c4 look how much you're weakening
the d5 square don't weaken don't weaken
central squares like that so casually
white has permanent outpost on d5
so the two setups that are generally
recommended here for black are well you
start with knight c6 either way
and now either e6 and then a6 or d6 and
e6
and then later you play e5 much much
later
i'll let you guys investigate this on
your own
so
one important point is that if black had
gone d6 who can tell me
what white should do this is a very
important point
this is a very very important point i'm
about to make what should white do
96 some of you are
are are jumping the gun here bishop f7
that doesn't really work
taking on d6 is bad you're helping black
untangle
bishop f4 is on the right track but it's
unnecessary the move is castles
you do nothing that's the answer
you're like what what about knight takes
e5 well this loses the queen
you know the drill bishop takes f7 and
king queen takes d8 okay but black
doesn't have to take any five of the
knight he can take with the pawn
the important thing to understand about
the smith mora is that even end games
are often terrible for black
look at this end game if king takes d8
then bishop takes f7 as possible or we
can give a check this is just like
devastating
whoops and what about knight takes d8
who can tell me what the devastating
move is here
this is winning on the spot for white
look around the board what squares can
you access
it's all about squares here it's all
about reaching
reaching squares
no not yeah knight b5 not knight d5
because of 96 not knight d5 because of
knight e6
but knight b5
because 96 you can take it now
knight heads for seaside is there really
no way to stop it yeah there's really no
way to stop it there's a hilarious line
if k27 get back get mated
boom i'm sure some games have ended this
way online
black has no other defense
okay so don't rule out lines just
because they get into an end
game so g6 we castle we go bishop f4
okay knight h6 exacerbates it but as i
was indicating many times e6
we immediately pay attention to the d6
square we had a game like this yesterday
we get one knight to d6 we get the other
knight to g5 we bust everything open and
we win the game easily knight h6 queen
d2 yeah knight f5 and just remember this
idea of going g4
just winning the night like that
this can come out of nowhere sometimes
this idea of like trapping the knight on
the side of the board can come out of
nowhere another idea that's similar
sometimes you have this situation
and you can play queen d2 and trap the
knight sorry
sometimes you have this situation you
can play queen d2 and trap the knight
like this
understood
that's it i mean here black should have
played knight takes e5 and this actually
is not so bad for black black has two
pieces two pawns for the piece we have a
lot of work to do
this this loses immediately one last
thing
a lot of you were falling in love with
h4h5
guys we don't you don't always need to
push your pawns up
in order to attack our pieces are
already enough and the thing is like
black can just ignore you
and okay congrats you gotta trade
but you've just spent three tempe
doing something relatively meaningless
understand why pawn storms are there in
the first place generally you storm with
your pawns in order to weaken your
opponent's king
here the king is already sufficiently
exposed and we're up a piece we don't
need more than that
i'm not trying to be frustrated but a
lot of you are
when you think attack you think h4h5
and that association has to go attack
doesn't mean h4 g4 h5 g5
so anyways that's that guys i don't have
much to say about this game
[Music]
you